let's go to the phones today 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 callers remember that when I say
your area code you won't hear like a
click or a chime or anything you just
got to know when I'm going to you so our
first caller is from the 2:01 area code
caller from 201 can you hear me are you
with us
hi David this is the live Mathews from
New Jersey great what's on your mind
today I was just wondering I am just 18
right now I got turned on to the left
movement from Bernie Sanders and
everything like that and the more and
more I looked the more lest I become and
when I say the more left I also mean
like you know at socialist ideas and
things like that and I just wanted to
ask if you had any idea on books or
anything like that on what I should read
to try and figure out where I am like
you know ideology well I mean so if you
want to figure out where you are you
sort of have to read a wide range of
things and figure out what resonates to
you I don't know if you are you looking
for socialist literature or are you
looking for just general political
literature I'm just trying to figure out
in general political literature like
what are the basics I should look into I
mean I think one interesting thing to
start with for me is if you really want
to do this the right way look into some
older reading right like go back and
read something like if you if you look
at the index the table of contents for
Bertrand Russell's history of Western
philosophy
I'm not saying read that book but look
at the list of people that are named in
their going all the way back to Greek
philosophy through Socrates Aristotle up
to and including more modern
philosophers Hobbes and etc that can
serve as a really good foundations for a
foundation for figuring out sort of the
underlying principles that resonate with
you and then after that you can start
looking into sort of more modern elected
officials or people that are associated
with political movement something else
you might want to do is take the
political compass test and then figure
out because when you finish that test
online it'll show you sort of like who
are you close to politically and who are
you further away from check out either
books about or by some of the people
that
appear on your political compass that's
one idea you have any other thoughts PAC
even just snippets of like a wealth of
nations by Adam Smith or the Leviathan
by Thomas Hobbes
one of my favorites is a theory of
justice by John Rawls check out those
that's there and while you're at it read
some marks as well right doesn't mean
you have to agree with everything that's
in there though those are some ideas
aligned Rand I ensure checkout and Rand
although some of our audience thinks
that I earn rands books were
sarcastically written like that it
wasn't meant to be taken seriously but
don't tell that to a libertarian right
Elias uh yeah no I've been reading the
Leviathan and things like that for my
European history class so you're on the
right track listen the fact that you
even asked for this question means
you're already way ahead of most people
all right cool thank you all right no
problem appreciate the call